The joe rogan experience.
Let's get into,
we,
we briefly touched on weight cutting,
but I know that the UFC has recognized that there's,
there's a real issue and um,
what steps have we taken to try to mitigate the problems that are caused by
weight cutting?
Yeah,
it was interesting and another one of the reasons why I love the performance
institute and the staff that we had there and that before them.
And it really stemmed from the Usada program where under the water code you ban
the use of Ivs.
And so,
cause I was kind of the point person obviously explained why ivs or problem,
it goes back to the,
to the cyclists.
They were using ivs to basically flush their system of drugs to manipulate their
bicycle biological passport.
So if is blood doping or using EPO and um,
it would have a tendency to lower those and,
and normalize those biological passport levels.
And so lot to learn that through some of the investigations that,
you know,
there were conducted and determined that ivy use in excess of 50 milliliters
every six hours would be prohibited.
So when we announced that we were adopting the water prohibited lists and
prohibited methods,
um,
there was some,
some blowback within the UFC community saying,
hey,
these things are used regularly because fighters are pushing themselves to the
edge to make weight and do you understand what you're doing here?
You're going to put fighters and unsafe positions where they're going to get in
and not be,
um,
rehydrated.
So we took a look at that and,
um,
spoke with you,
saw it,
and he said,
hey,
you know,
maybe we should,
slowly rolled out the ivy bands.
So we actually delayed that by three months.
The program went into effect July 1st and we instituted the IB band,
um,
October 1st.
So we had three months of getting fighters prepared for it,
educating them why,
um,
that they were banned.
Nevertheless,
I mean,
real quickly the whole weight cutting issue came kind of into my plate.
And while,
you know,
I wasn't an expert in it,
I had to get out and talk to a lot of fighters,
camps,
coaches about ivs and give them,
you know,
alternatives to rehydrating the right way.
And so I,
again,
not being an expert myself,
I reached out to what I found were we're experts in the world.
A certain guy by name of Doctor Robert Kenefick who is a phd exercise
physiologist,
works at the US Army Research Institute of Environmental Medicine Studies,
environmental effects on soldiers,
his expertise being dehydration.
So soldiers in the Middle East that are marching for hours,
days upon a time run out of water,
dehydrate themselves.
How do we get these fighters back?
Are these soldiers back rehydrated and back into the fight and thought,
hey,
this is the type of expert that we need to talk to.
Its extreme dehydration.
Not,
you know,
some kid that has diarrhea,
it's mildly dehydrated with some,
some pedialyte.
So we brought him in.
Um,
had him actually the week of UFC 200,
um,
he was in town,
got a chance to talk to lot of the,
the fighters coming in and analyze the message they were using.
Um,
he recommended to us,
hey,
you know,
here's the maximum amount of weight fighters,
that you should recommend.
Fighters are losing that fight week.
And that's how we came up with our weight guideline of 8%.
So we recommend when those fighters check in Tuesday for a Saturday fight,
they're within 8% of their goal weight,
usually on Friday.
I'm not a requirement or recommendation,
but you know,
we put that out there and educated heavily on that.
Um,
since then,
uh,
you talked,
I think last week about Andy Foster,
the executive director of California who's really taken the lead in terms of
commissions on combating dangerous weight cutting.
Um,
he worked with US pretty closely on developing his 10 point weight cutting plan
or plan to combat serious weight cutting.
Um,
includes his commission making calls to fighters on the car 30 days out,
10 days out,
making them a little bit more accountable,
uh,
farther out than fight week.
Um,
he's also got a provision where fight night,
he takes the fighters weight,
weighs them and their recommendation is you only put on 10% of your weight back
on plus a pound.
Um,
if they're over that California can recommend the fight or move up a weight
class.
Um,
so really,
yeah,
I mean just a lot of,
you know,
education recommendations,
not here.
A lot of people talk about,
and I'm curious for your thoughts on this,
hey,
we can,
we can stop this instantaneously.
See instantaneously just put rules out there.
If you lose this much weight or put this much weight back on,
you're suspended for six months,
12 months,
you know,
whatever your,
we're just not going to let you,
you fight my concern.
There's,
when you have absolute rules,
fighter's going to do everything possible to,
you know,
to make weight.
Say you had a rule that if you miss,
wait,
you can't fight it again for 12 months.
You have to move up a weight class fighter's going to kill themselves to make
weight.
My fear would be that you,
you put an absolute rule out there and someone get hurts because of the rule
that you put in place,
which is,
hey,
you know,
I think it's a measured approach.
You have to continually reevaluate it.
But I think right now the rules that are out there between our recommendations,
California's rules are more guideline recommendations.
And then that in conjunction with what we're doing at the performance institute
where,
I mean,
you saw last week there was no excuse if you have issues making weight or you're
not sure what your weight class is,
that you have every resource available the best in the world to you to come in
and find that out,
to be given a plan on how to safely and make weight.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's,
it's a multimillion dollar investment that the UFC has put I think toward that
problem and you know,
hey,
maybe two,
three years from now we say,
hey,
that was with good intentions,
but not enough.
We need to do more.
But I think right now,
um,
that's our strategy,
uh,
on the issue.
Well,
I think a couple things would have to happen to really stop weight cutting.
One thing you're going to have to blow up these weight classes because there's
going to be champions in these weight classes that really won't be in that
weight class anymore.
If you cut all the real heavy duty weight cutting out of the picture.
I think what one FC is trying to do is they're,
they're doing hydration test and they do a series of them.
I believe they do three leading up to the fight,
which really was it.
Benevidez was telling me this,
someone,
someone was telling me this,
um,
that they've essentially made it almost impossible for you to cut weight.
So they do an hydration test on weighing at the way they're doing hydration test
three different times,
three different times leading up to the fight.
I don't know the exact protocol,
but what they've done is essentially made it so that you can't be dehydrated.
Like you can't,
when you weigh in,
you have to weigh in and as you know,
like if you're fighting at one 70 but you know,
you,
you get on the scale and you're fucking dying.
Like they're like,
no,
you're not really one 70 like,
and that,
that's really where it should be.
This idea that the best way to fight is to cheat and to drain all yourself of
fluids and then pretend that you're 160 pounds,
then get back on the scale,
you know,
15 hours later at one 85.
That's fucking crazy.
That doesn't make any sense.
You're not really 160 pound fighter.
You're 185 pound fighter who almost died.
Yeah,
it's interesting,
you know,
if talk with forests a lot about this because he went through it and again why
he's such a great asset to,
to the probe,
to the company.
Uh,
but he says,
look,
there's certain guys and girls that have,
uh,
genetic,
um,
ability to,
to carry,
you know,
the have good muscle mass.
Usually that just carry a ton of water and it's not,
it's not difficult.
It's not dangerous for them to drop 10 or 15 pounds.
But it would be if they fought 15 pounds under c.
If,
if they're a fighting at 170 pounds,
they really weigh one 85 and if they cut down to one 70 they make that weight
and then thought right then,
then it would be dangerous.
Their performance would be radically diminished.
So we're lying when those people get on the scale,
when they get on the scale and they flex and they say one 70 sure you're one 70
for about an hour,
you know,
and then you're going to go right back up to what you were before you dehydrated
yourself.
This is madness to me.
Goes against what fighting is supposed to be.
What we talked about before about discipline and focus and and and technique and
training.
That's what competing is supposed to be about.
It's supposed to be about a fight or two equally skillful individuals try to
figure out who's got the best strategy and who's got the best we'll and
technique.
It's not supposed to be about who can do this legal cheating thing best cause.
That's what weight cutting is.
You know,
really the modern history of the UFC.
And the reason I think it's so successful is the Renzo and Dana ran toward
regulation,
right?
Yes.
They said,
hey,
this is a no,
you know,
marketed as an no rules,
no hold bar event.
They ran toward rules.
And so I think you know what you're talking and I actually had a discussion with
Bob then at about this executive director of Nevada.
He's Graham last week and you know,
he's looking what California is doing.
He says,
look,
we have physicals after the way in.
So you know,
we do the way it is now at the host hotel.
So it's usually done at a ballroom fighter,
gets up on the scale,
makes weight immediately,
goes behind the curtain and has their pre-fight physical.
Right.
But do they have a hydration test?
They don't.
I know California does some hydration testing fight night.
But would Bob told me is I have the most experience,
ringside physicians in the world that have seen more,
you know,
combat sports events and everywhere.
I'm comfortable that these guys are evaluating these medical professionals or
evaluating these fighters in this scenario.
And if they feel or see is not safe for that fight or to compete the next night
that they'll call them off.
I think that's wonderful.
But I think all that does is keep fighters from getting to the point of death.
I mean,
getting to the point where they're sick and Tara,
they're definitely compromised when they're making the weight.
They're not really at that weight.
What I would really love in a perfect world,
besides the bare knuckle thing,
what I would really love is a weight class every 10 pounds.
Just have every time.
I mean there's just giant gaps.
The gap between 85 and two oh five is 20 fucking pounds.
That's a lot of weight.
I hear that.
But let me give you a scenario where it shows that alone and can work female new
division for the UFC one 25 right?
Because we had a one 15 to one 35 pound gap,
right?
What happened in our first championship fight,
so Jara Eubanks couldn't make weight.
She,
she wasn't even there.
That in and of itself,
just making a weight class I don't think solves the problem.
But she's also relatively inexperienced young to sport and this is a brand new
way class that they really didn't have a,
like,
I'm not saying he had more weight classes wouldn't help,
but they're not going to help by themselves.
You gotta it's gotta be a multiple ag wrong attack.
I think the hydration test should be along with that,
the hydration test and weight classes every 10 pounds and then give the champion
the benefit of the doubt.
Like whoever is the champion,
each division,
whatever,
whatever weight class,
you know what we find out what they really way and they have an opportunity to
fight for the title in that weight class.
You have to,
I think we talked about it when you her through the Pie,
but we have on a couple of occasion use that bioelectrical impedance machine to
determine is that the proper term?
I don't know.
Um,
but it basically can,
you know,
you step on the scale and you,
you hold on these handles and it gives you some type of hydration reading.
Um,
we've done that a few times on checking day,
weigh in day.
We're not sure exactly what the numbers look like,
but that's something that,
you know,
we're looking into.
Clint also does a lot of specific gravity testing fight week on fighters where
you know,
it'll be a Tuesday or Wednesday and I think he showed you that,
that chart.
Um,
he'll look at how much weight fighter has to lose and then look at what their
specific gravity reading is,
how diluted or concentrated the urine is.
And you know,
if you see someone with a bunch of weight to lose that is,
you know,
relatively dehydrated specific gravity wise,
then you know,
it can alter their plans.
So yeah,
I mean we've got a lot of,
a lot of that stuff going on.
I don't necessarily disagree with you that that more needs to be done the right
now our plan of attack is to use these resources,
use the facility of the pie.
You know,
in an ideal world,
I think rather than making these absolute rules,
trying to educate our fighters,
trying to show them,
I tell you one thing,
you can talk until you're blue in the face about things being bad,
unhealthy for a fighter.
They're like,
I'm bullet proof.
Not only that,
they're fighters,
they're fighting.
That's bad for you anyway.
Right?
Like,
oh,
cut and weights bad for me too.
Okay.
Where they start listening,
and I think this is where the performance institute comes into play when you
start talking about the effect on your performance.
Um,
so if you tell them,
hey look,
if you can come to,
you know,
your proper weight and a more measured approach and not lose a whole bunch and
put that one look,
look at the difference it's gonna make on your performance 24 to 30 hours later
because you see this,
I mean,
you see this occasionally when fighters go through,
you know,
tough weight cuts.
You see them softer around her too.
Right?
Oh good.
He's looked moving up to 170 pounds.
I mean,
it's just phenomenal.
I also think now it's interesting,
there's,
you know,
on one side of it the criticism would be,
well you're just encouraging even greater weight cuts and regains.
But I think this morning weigh and thing that we've,
we've put together I think has had a positive impact in a couple of areas.
Explain that for people in the world we're talking about.
Yeah.
So actually Andy Foster again,
California before UFC 199 came to me and said,
hey,
we've been doing this morning weigh in for a couple of regional local shows.
Would you guys be interested in it?
Where we do it at the host hotel,
we do it,
you know,
we'd open the scales from 9:00 AM to 11:00 AM and the idea would be a fighter
gets on weight in their hotel room,
upstairs,
hops on the elevator steps on the scale.
They make weight,
they can start eating and drinking again right away with the idea of they don't
have to wait until 4:00 PM and that's exactly what the idea of,
I think one of the dangers of,
you know,
weight cutting and being dehydrated is the amount of time that you're at a,
at a loss of that water.
And in the past when we'd have the weigh ins at an arena,
um,
it would be the fighter would have to check in.
Downstairs we had the way ends at four o'clock in an arena,
the firewood,
the fighter with check in downstairs that maybe two,
um,
two 30 the bus would leave.
I remember when Rio were in one time on a bus for an hour,
hour and a half to the arena.
Everybody's depleted and dehydrated on the bus ride,
you step on a scale and a cold,
you know,
environmentally unfriendly arena.
You then get back on the bus drive another hour,
hour and a half.
You're talking multiple hours where these fighters are in a depleted state.
So I think the morning way and protects against that.
I think the other benefit we've seen out of it,
and I think it's more of a longterm than a short term benefit,
is we've seen a lot more fighters missing weight since we went to the morning
weigh ins and I think that's a product of timing and that in the past you had
four,
you know,
four or five in the afternoon,
you had all day long to cut weight and you would see fighters at 10 or 11 said,
I can't do anymore and a one or two o'clock.
I said,
no,
I can do a couple more pounds and just all day long now,
unless you're literally not sleeping the night before you fight,
you have a shorter window in the morning to do that.
And I think a lot of those myths,
weights has help identify those fighters that I'm probably in the right,
the wrong weight class.
I can't make that weight of waking up,
you know,
five or six in the morning,
a couple hours and it's probably too much weight to lose.
And we've seen some fighters move up in weight class because of that.
We've also seen some fighters that have decided,
hey,
I gotta take this more professionally and hire a nutritionist.
Like could be,
could be a number of Madoff who made weight easily for his last fight and the
fight before that obviously fell out of the fight because his body shut down.
He had to go to the hospital.
It'd be rehydrated.
Yeah,
I mean I,
again,
I don't think it's a one size fits all solution.
You have to be careful.
Hey Habib,
missed weight that last time.
Went to the hospital.
You don't have a knee jerk reaction would be you.
You can't fight this weight anymore.
What we saw this time,
he just changed the way he did things.
He came in,
he was on wait the night before.
He had a couple of pounds to lose fight week.
Yeah.
So it can be done and again,
that reverts back to the performance institute.
I think there's no excuse now that if you're a new fighter and you're not making
a hell of a lot of money and don't have the resources to hire,
you know,
George Lockhart,
whoever you now have,
Clint Wattenberg,
who's an ivy league educated Sports Dietitian that can provide you all that
remotely.
If you can't get to Vegas,
he'll give you a full plan over,
you know,
over the phone,
over email.
Um,
if you can get to Vegas,
not only will Clint plan things out for you,
but you have a kitchen and cooks and staff that will provide you that meal
throughout your whole fight camp.
I just want to be there for free.
Yeah.